erst mal noch weniger kontakt zu
weihnachten dann aber spielraum bund und
länder legen gerade die richtung für den
corona winterfest vorsichtiges aufatmen
in frankreich die besonders harten
beschränkungen dort sollen zumindest ein
bisschen gelockert werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tod eines idols diego maradona war für
viele der beste spieler aller zeiten er
wurde 60 jahre alt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber guten abend in allen
und ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns in
diesem wichtigen nachrichten tag der
blick auf den sport nachher mit katjas
tresoren trauriger tag für den fußball
ganz genau und argentinien hat
angekündigt drei tage staatstrauer gehen
zu wollen einen guten namen
das ist der tag heute auch an dem klar
werden soll wie es weitergeht mit den
chor ohne einschränkungen für
deutschland die bundeskanzlerin
konferiert mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidentin
der länder und das hier ist der stand
aktuell einige planungen waren schon vor
dem treffen sehr konkret zum beispiel
die kontakt beschränkungen maximal fünf
leute aus zwei haushalten sollen sich
treffen dürfen kinder bis 14 nicht
mitgezählt über andere maßnahmen wurde
noch gestritten dürfen weniger kunden in
die läden ab wann müssen schulen ihre
klassen verkleinern
und wer bezahlt hilfsgelder an
unternehmen seit fünf stunden ringen die
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin um
neue chor ohne regelungen und eine
einigung scheint schwieriger als gedacht
offenbar soll es aber weitere
einschränkungen geben für gebiete mit
besonders hohen zahlen an infektionen
gedacht ist wohl an ein incidents wehrt
ab 200 umstritten ist dagegen weiter die
frage ob die kontakt beschränkungen die
zu weihnachten gelockert werden soll
an silvester nicht wieder strenger
gehandhabt werden müssen
ich bin bei silvester das gebe ich zu
etwas zurückhalten denn weihnachten ist
das fest der familie
silvester natürlich mehr das fest der
freunde und ob man da auch die gleiche
zahlen mit zehn leuten beispielsweise
machen soll da bin ich zurückhaltend das
müssen wir heute noch mal besprechen
strittig ist auch noch wie die auflagen
für schulen genau aussehen sollen klar
ist offenbar nur dass die ferien
vorgezogen werden wenn man die
großeltern besuchen will da macht es
sinn was auch karl lauterbach gesagt hat
dass man da ein paar tage vorher nicht
in der schule ist und deswegen ist das
auch gut und richtig dass die
schulferien früher anfangen wohl wissend
dass das für die eltern eine belastung
ist klar ist wir müssen uns demnächst
wieder auf schlangen vor kaufhäusern und
supermärkten
einrichten offenbar wollen kanzleramt
und länder das sich in großen geschäften
künftig höchstens ein kunde pro 20
quadratmeter aufhalten darf kritik jetzt
diskutierte regel würde die innenstädte
zu ethnischen werden lassen und zum
anderen wäre es ein programm zur
beschaffung neuer marktanteile bei
amazon aus der opposition kommt vor
allem eine forderung es brauche
langfristige und bundesweit einheitliche
coroner regeln
das hick-hack was wir in den letzten
tagen wieder hatten das macht die leute
fertig und es wird auch nicht zu
sicherheit das wird auch nicht dazu dass
alle sagen ich muss mich daran halten
doch im kanzleramt geht es auch um die
details und um die wird weiter gerungen
denn ein scheitern der gespräche wie in
der letzten woche können sich beide
seiten nicht leisten
ja die bundesländer hatten eigentlich
vorab gesagt wir haben das vorab
weitgehend geklärt bereits jetzt dauert
es aber doch länger als gedacht bei
dieser video-konferenz theo wo sind denn
die aktuellen knackpunkte ja ganz
offensichtlich verhakt man sich bei
vielmehr punkten als vorher gedacht und
als die vielen vertraulichen vorlagen
vermuten ließen ich habe gerade vor
einer minute eine sms bekommen man ist
jetzt auf seite 10 von 15 oder 16 seiten
vorbereitungen die interessen und
betroffenheiten der bundesländer sind
schlicht zu unterschiedlich und dann
kommt noch die strenge haltung des
kanzleramts obendrauf eben zum beispiel
gab es streit um die frage was in den
hotspots mit über 200 inzidenz wird
zusätzlich gewacht gemacht werden müsse
die verhandler waren so verhakt dass sie
eine auszeit nehmen musste und
offensichtlich haben sie dann die länder
haben sich durchgesetzt es bleibt in
ihrem eigenen ermessen und dem länder
ermessen könnte am ende auch bleiben
ob die weihnachts lockerungen bis über
silvester gelten oder nicht dann
allerdings bekämen wir eine art
flickenteppich der festivitäten und dann
gibt es zusätzlich offenbar jetzt auch
noch streit ums geld nämlich
insbesondere um die
entschädigungszahlungen dann auch für
eine längere zeit nämlich auch für den
dezember zum beispiel was ist denn da zu
hören wer soll das zahlen also die
dezember entschädigung zahlt
offensichtlich der bund wir insgesamt
bisher finanziell vieles zu lasten des
bundes geht die länder
sind die wesentlichen entscheider der
chef der unions fraktion hat deshalb
schon im vorfeld klar gemacht ist es so
nicht weitergeht und dass die länder ab
januar die entschädigung für unternehmen
mit bezahlen müssen und die kanzlerin
soll heute in der sitzung gesagt haben
der bund werde nicht den ganzen winter
übernehmen
und natürlich sind die nötigen
milliarden durchaus ein nicht ganz
unwichtiger hebel auch in den
verhandlungen ganz aktuelle
informationen live aus berlin von theo
koll die grundlage für all das ist die
korona situation in deutschland da gibt
es heute eine bedrückende rekordzahl 410
tote in 24 stunden
wo wir im moment stehen zeigt der blick
auf die kurve der neuinfektionen seit
märz die zweite welle ist massiver als
die erste doch der aktuelle verlauf gibt
etwas hoffnung seit zwei wochen steigt
die zahl der neuen infektionen nicht
mehr explosionsartig aber immer noch
kommen im sieben tage schnitt etwa
18.500 neuinfektionen jeden tag dazu auf
den intensivstationen zeigt sich eine
entwicklung erst bis zu 14 tage später
so steigt die zahl der mit kuwait
patienten belegten intensivbetten
momentan noch täglich weiter an
es gibt aber bei den betten auch noch
kapazitäten und dann schauen wir noch
auf die zahlen von heute der
neuinfektionen 18 1633 hat das robert
koch institut in den vergangenen 24
stunden registriert 1072 mehr als
vergangenen mittwoch wir gehen natürlich
live nach berlin wenn es dort eine
einigung gibt während dieser sendung
weitere infos zum corona gipfel im
kanzleramt auch in einem zdf spezial
gleich nach uns und natürlich in der
zdf- heute- app die fast sobald sie denn
dann klar sind auch alle beschlossenen
regeln noch mal für sie zusammen
frankreich lockert seine corona
maßnahmen und doch stöhnen viele
franzosen weiter unter den
beschränkungen
die regeln waren hart die ihnen
präsident manual makro schon vor wochen
vorgeschrieben hatte strikte
ausgangssperren etwa nur notwendige
geschäfte geöffnet sonst nahezu alles
dicht
denn auch die zweite welle hatte
frankreich voll erwischt mit bis zu
60.000 neuinfektionen pro tag
inzwischen sind es unter 20.000 daher
jetzt ein bisschen locker und thomas
walde
die ausgangssperre wirke sagte manual
makro frankreichs infektionszahlen
sinken der höhepunkt der zweiten welle
sei überstanden
bei meiner letzten ansprache
befürchteten wir eine deutlich
schlechtere tendenz aber wir haben das
geändert dank unserer anstrengungen dank
ihrer anstrengungen der gemeinsinn den
sie bewiesen haben zeigt wirkung häufig
es am 28.11 dürfen kleine geschäfte
wieder öffnen mitte dezember gilt die
ausgangssperre nur noch nachts dürfen
museen und kinos öffnen und ende januar
dann restaurants sportstudios und
weiterführende schulen
das alles aber nur wenn die
infektionszahlen weiter zurückgehen ist
das eine gute strategie ich weiß es
nicht ich denke es ist wichtig für jeden
von uns sein leben weiterführen zu
können
das ist recht positiv ändert aber nicht
allzu viel für uns hier in paris das ist
ein wenig enttäuschend
ich denke es bleiben maßnahmen die nicht
angemessen sind
mit den schrittweisen an bedingungen
geknüpfte lockerungen will die regierung
verhindern dass die infektion zum
patientenzahlen erneut in die höhe
schnellen
nur durch wir müssen alles tun um eine
dritte welle und eine dritte
ausgangssperre zu vermeiden
trotzdem profi marko kündigte zum
jahreswechsel impfungen an
sie sollen freiwillig sein frankreich
atmet ein wenig durch an dem tag an dem
es seinen 50.000 toten zählte unser
nächstes thema
der krieg ist erst mal vorbei jetzt wird
in der kaukasusregion berg karabach die
macht neu verteilt
nach dem waffenstillstand mit armenien
übernimmt aserbaidschan in vielen
bezirken die kontrolle
insgesamt in zwei drittel der umkämpften
region weite teile der armenischen
bevölkerung fordern deswegen den
rücktritt der eigenen regierung
armenische truppen haben einen bezirk
bereits vor
von dort sind massenhaft zivilisten
geflüchtet
nächste woche wird der nächste bezirk
übergeben und seit heute übernimmt
aserbaidschan die macht im bezirk
karbatsche von dort berichtet für begabt
punkt mitternacht die meldung aus baku
das aserbaidschanische militär hat die
region kambodscha übernommen kurz zuvor
bereitete nicole sich darauf vor seine
heimat in bergkarabach zu verlassen
als wir ihn um seine meinung bitten
fragt der arminia erstmal ob er fluchen
dürfe die menschen hier haben einfach
ihr leben gelebt jetzt müssen alle ihre
häuser zurück lassen fliehen
manche nehmen sogar die grabsteine ihrer
mütter und väter mit das zeigt doch wie
verzweifelt sie sind knapp 2000 soldaten
aus russland sollen die waffenruhe
zwischen den verfeindeten nachbarn
armenien und aserbaidschan sichern
entlang der neuen grenzen die noch nicht
genau abgesteckt sind wen nun russische
fahnen
ich möchte ihm dafür danken dass mein
sohn noch liebt dass er jetzt ein
kriegsheld ist wem wollen sie danken
wladimir wladimirowitsch putin ein
drittel der region berg karabach bleibt
unter armenischer kontrolle
hier beginnt der wiederaufbau larissa
ist gerade zurückgekehrt
sie war mit der ganzen familie vor dem
krieg geflohen nicht zum letzten mal
befürchtet die armenierin das war nicht
der letzte krieg diese geschichte ist
nicht vorbei berg karabach dieser tage
eine region beherrscht von misstrauen
unsicherheit und großer trauer und wir
gehen live zu für basiszins der parkett
der hauptstadt von berg karabach guten
filme ist das jetzt eine situation die
tatsächlich irgendwie stabil sein kann
oder bricht der krieg bald wieder neu
aus
also wir haben hier in den letzten tagen
tatsächlich armenische soldaten
getroffen die ihre kalaschnikows unterm
bett aufbewahren
für den fall dass sie zurück an die
front geschickt werden und ganz
allgemein ist eine große unsicherheit
bei den menschen hier in bergkarabach zu
spüren ob sie diesem frieden trauen
können im wahrsten sinne des wortes aber
solange moskau und ankara eine interesse
an diesem waffenstillstand haben und
russische soldaten diesen
waffenstillstand auch überwachen denke
ist es eher unwahrscheinlich dass in
nächster zeit wieder ein krieg hier in
bergkarabach ausbrechen wird live aus
berg karabach herzlichen dank zurück
nach deutschland die bundesregierung hat
ein zeichen gegen diskriminierung
gesetzt so sollen homosexuelle soldaten
der bundeswehr und der ehemaligen
volksarmee der ddr per gesetz
rehabilitiert werden weil damit
gerichtsurteile gegen sie aufgehoben
werden
militärgerichte hatten soldaten
verurteilt weil sie einvernehmlichen sex
hatten und es gibt eine entschädigung
von 3000 euro
auch für soldaten die wegen ihrer
sexuellen orientierung entlassen oder
nicht befördert wurden das
verteidigungsministerium beziffert die
zahl der betroffenen auf etwa 1.000 nun
zu einer anderen zahl die sehr
erschüttert jeden dritten tag wird in
diesem land statistisch gesehen eine
frau durch ihren partner oder ex-partner
umgebracht gewalt gegen frauen ist an
der tagesordnung und die korona
situation macht es noch schlimmer
darauf machen organisationen in ganz
deutschland aufmerksam und strahlen
heute am sogenannten ohren steif
verschiedene gebäude an
sie fordern alle auf sich aktiv gegen
gewalt einzusetzen
nicht nur in der luft auch auf der
schiene sorgt die korona pandemie für
riesige verluste ein minus von 5,6
milliarden euro drohe bei der deutschen
bahn für dieses jahr schreibt die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
die zahl der bahn fahrgäste geht stark
zurück fernzüge sind im schnitt nur noch
zu 20 prozent ausgelastet um die
verluste abzufedern hat der bund
zugesagt das eigenkapital um 5
milliarden euro zu erhöhen
die arbeit vieler europäischer forscher
ist weltspitze drei top ideen
konkurrieren in diesem jahr um den
deutschen zukunftspreis und seit wenigen
minuten ist klar gewonnen hat ein
projekt das es ermöglicht immer kleinere
und leistungsfähigere mikro chips
herzustellen etwa für smartphones oder
roboter wo herkömmliche verfahren an
grenzen kommen setzen die entwickler aus
baden württemberg und thüringen
extremisten v licht ein
der schirmherr bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier überreichte mit
abstand den preis an die gewinner bei
einer feier in berlin den deutschen
zukunftspreis 2020 mit allen details
sehen sie hier im zdf- heute abend um 22
uhr 45
so jetzt zu einem der millionen menschen
bewegt hat nicht nur in der welt des
fußballs diego maradona ist tot
ein genie auf dem platz aber eines mit
problemen
jenseits der stadien der weltmeister von
186 war vor 14 tagen aus einem
krankenhaus in buenos aires entlassen
worden
dort hatte man ihn wegen eines
blutgerinnsels im gehirn operiert
heute ist der argentinier keine vier
wochen nach seinem sechzigsten
geburtstag nach einem herzinfarkt
gestorben maradonas krankenakte war lang
er erlitt mindestens zwei herzinfarkte
und war mehrfach wegen seiner
drogensucht in behandlung
der nachruf von andreas kürten jetzt auf
eine fußballlegende ein leben zwischen
extremen diego armando maradona auf dem
platz einer der besten fußballer aller
zeiten abseits des platzes oft
gestrauchelt aufgewachsen in einem
vorort von buenos aires bereits mit 15
debütiert das ausnahmetalent in der
ersten argentinischen liga
[Musik]
mit 21 wechselt er nach spanien zum
großen fc barcelona später gewinnt er in
italien mit neapel meisterschaft und
uefa-cup und wird zum liebling der
massen zum weltstar avanciert er bei der
wm 1986 mit seinem tor des jahrhunderts
gegen england
im selben spiel sein umstrittenster
treffer maradona spricht von der hand
gottes und wird wenig später mit
argentinien weltmeister das privatleben
des super-stars ist stets begleitet von
skandalen 1991 wird ihm kokain konsum
nachgewiesen anklagen wegen
drogenhandels und zuhälterei
es beginnt der abstieg mit
entziehungskuren gescheiterten comeback
versuchen und immer neuen skandalen
dennoch bleibt diego armando maradona
ein nationales symbol argentiniens und
für viele der größte fußballer aller
zeiten sehr viel zu früher tod eines
idols katja gibt's denn schon reaktionen
ja genau ein anderer großer fußballer
nämlich pele aus brasilien schrieb ich
habe einen ehemaligen gefährten verloren
die welt eine legende eines tages
spielen wir hoffentlich gemeinsam
fußball im himmel das dauert hoffentlich
noch ein bisschen
absolut ja wo es noch weitere
nachrichten vom spruch genau ganz kurz
noch der hinweis werde das gesamte spiel
1986 wm finale sehen will argentinien
deutschland bei uns auf zdf sport.de
jetzt aber zum aktuellen fußball gestern
abend fußball-champions-league zwischen
paris langsamer und rb leipzig mit dem
besseren ende für die franzosen 1 0 der
endstand im schlüsselspiel der gruppe h
beide trainer gefrustet vor allem rb
coach julia nagelsmann nach einer
strittigen entscheidung
schiedsrichter und video assistent waren
sich offenbar einig es war ein foul auch
wenn in der zeitlupe eine berührung von
ángel di maría durch marcel sabitzer
nicht zu erkennen ist
es ist schon eine krasse
fehlentscheidung sondern bedeutenden
spiel
diesen elfmeter zu geben den ich einfach
nicht nachvollziehen kann es gibt
einfach null komma null kontakt psg
superstar neymar verwandelt den
foulelfmeter zum 1 0
ansonsten nicht
sie sehen vom star ensemble leipzig die
dominierende mannschaft mehr ballbesitz
mehr torabschlüsse aber eben kein tor
trotzig muss sich thomas tuchel
kritische fragen gefallen lassen und
reagiert empört
wenn sie die eier haben dann kommen sie
in die kabinen und fragen sie die
spieler da finden sie einige die alles
gegeben haben so viel mehr grund zur
freude hatte der pvp 13 0 gegen brügge
es fehlt nur noch ein punkt zum
achtelfinale kölling holland erneut mit
einem doppelpack dazu ein freistoß tor
von jason holland bereits mit 16 toren
in zwölf champions league partie das
schafften noch nicht einmal messi und
ronaldo
der fc schalke steckt richtig tief in
der krise tabellenplatz 18 also letzter
0 siege 24 gegentreffer dazu trennte
sich der verein gestern vom technischen
direktor michael reschke suspendierte
zwei spieler und warf einen sogar ganz
raus der vertrag mit vedad ibisevic wird
zum jahresende aufgelöst nabi ben taleb
und amina ried sollen erst mal
individuell trainieren und michael
reschke ist sofort weg es hat früh in
der saison schon etwas von einem
verzweifelten rundumschlag was da gerade
auf schalke passiert
tretet ihren dich nicht um
einzelschicksale sondern es geht darum
wie wir mit der mannschaft aus dieser
situation herauskommen sport vorstand
jochen schneider gibt sich
selbstkritisch im mediengespräch hat am
vormittag einen deutlichen appell an die
mannschaft gerichtet
aber wir brauchen diesen diesen diesen
allen mitspieler teamgedanke miteinander
ansonsten wird es wird es schwer
am samstag geht es in der bundesliga
nach mönchengladbach keine gute zeit für
schalke fans katja vielen dank wir
können jetzt alle gemeinsamen uns noch
schnell die lottozahlen angucken
die lauten wie folgt 10 11 16 17 18 30
superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7 ruhiges
novemberwetter sagen die meteorologen
zudem da draußen grund hat er hat gleich
alle details ich habe das heute schon
mal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
gegen 22 uhr 15 sie hat fragen an
kanzleramtsminister helge braun gleich
nach uns das zdf spezial zu den
beschlüssen in berlin noch sitzen sie ja
dort zusammen
und morgen sind wir dann hier wieder für
sie da punkt 7 für heute danke fürs
zuschauen und in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
gute nahm die zuschauer morgen wird sie
in norddeutschland wieder trüb sein der
höchste luftdruck liegt ja schon so
leicht östlich von uns und deshalb kann
eine kleine regenfront von der nordsee
morgen norddeutschland erreichen aber es
fällt nur sehr wenig regnen regen aber
es ist halt wolkig und ganz anderer
regen fällt vor allem hier in portugal
spanien marokko und auf den bergen
schneit es dort sogar heute nacht bei
uns dichte nebelfelder zum teil
sichtweite in süd deutschland unter 100
meter morgen früh beginnt an der nordsee
leicht zu regnen und an den küsten und
im nordwesten bleibt es dann frostfrei
sonst bekommen wir frost zwischen 0 und
-6 grad und tagsüber wird es in
süddeutschland auf den bergen wieder am
mildesten das sind es 13 grad im
schwarzwald an der donau bei nebel nur 0
bis 5 und mit dem frischen west während
in norddeutschland immerhin sieben bis
elf grad ja es wird trübt seine
norddeutschland immer wieder regnet
leicht an der nordsee kommt dann
allerdings die sonne raus war dem
frischen wind und auch über den
mittelgebirgen wird es langsam heller
die sonne kommt vor allen dingen auf den
bergen dort in den niederungen bleibt es
in süddeutschland meist wieder trüb
höchstens dass am rhein auch die sonne
wieder mal rauskommt die aussichten
freitag geht es eigentlich ganz ähnlich
weiter samstag und sonntag es wird das
osten kühler und auch wieder etwas
sonniger
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut